hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live
manche glaubten dass sei ein
Hollywood-Film und erwarteten jetzt
Ergebnisse aber so ist es nicht auf dem
Spiel stehen Menschenleben das sagte der
ukrainische Präsident vor rund zwei
Wochen über die Gegenoffensive seiner
Armee seitdem sind viele seiner Soldaten
gestorben die Kämpfe gegen die
russischen Besatzer sie sind zäh und sie
sind blutig insbesondere im Osten soll
die Lage aktuell derzeit sehr schwierig
sein die russischen Truppen haben im
Süden und Osten rund 200.000
Quadratkilometer vermint es sind
Kilometer tief gestaffelte Anlagen die
die russisch besetzten Gebiete absichern
sollen zuerst kommen die Minenfelder die
einen Angriff erschweren sogenannte
Drachenzähne aus Beton verhindern dass
Panzer schnell durchkommt und
ausgehobene schützen Gräben bieten
Schutz für die russischen Soldaten dann
kommen Panzergräben und bilden die
gesamte Verteidigungslinie mit Arterie
und Raketenwerfer
da stellt sich die Frage kann die
Ukraine dagegen überhaupt ankommen dass
es heute unser Thema wir haben uns dazu
einen Gast eingeladen wie bei der über
diese Frage zu sprechen kann Kiew seine
Ziele noch erreichen deswegen ist jetzt
bei uns und was da die Wolfgang Richter
schön dass Sie bei uns sind hallo
hallo guten Abend Frage ihr könnt Fragen
stellen an oberstad Richter und zwar
natürlich die erste Frage die wir uns
jetzt hier zu Anfang stellen die
Offensive da heißt es immer die ersten
Wochen sind entscheidend die ersten
Wochen sind vorbei wie ist denn die
aktuelle Lage
ja die aktuelle Lage ist so wie Sie das
am Anfang ja schon geschildert haben
also die Russen haben sich sehr stark
für barrikatiert mit Minenfeldern mit
sehr starken konzentrierten
artilleriewaffen und Panzer und Panzer
Abwehrkräften sie haben die Fehler nicht
mehr wiederholt diese anfangs in den
ersten Kriegsmonaten gemacht haben sie
organisieren besser sie können
Artillerie Feuer und Aufklärung und dann
die Bewegung der Druck besser
organisieren die Verteidigung tut sich
ja generell etwas leichter als eine
angriffsoperation die Schwierigkeiten
liegen jetzt auf der ukrainischen Seite
und Sie müssen in der Tat sehen wo die
Weichen stellen sind wenn es überhaupt
solche gibt aber das haben sie versucht
es gab also sowohl an der östlichen
Front in Richtung Johann jetzt
natürlich diese Versuche der Ukraine
durch taktische Angriffe auf breitere
Front verschiedene Angriffe diese
Schwachstellen herauszufinden es gab
offenbar keine sie haben es im Süden
probiert
also an der Schnittstelle zwischen den
beiden oblasten saporos hier am Donezk
in Richtung Mariupol auch da ist es sehr
schwer geworden man versucht jetzt
Erfolge dadurch zu melden dass man also
Quadratkilometer er misst das muss man
natürlich relativieren dann im Gefecht
heißt das dass man vielleicht
vorgeschobene Stellung werfen kann bis
man an die Hauptverteidigungslinie
herankommt und dann sind es in der Tat
schon zwei drei Kilometer die man
gewinnen kann das ist aber noch kein
operativer Erfolg das ist ein Versuch
abzukasten man muss dazu sagen die
Ukraine haben bisher etwa ein Drittel
ihrer strategischen Reserve also mit
westlichen Waffen eingesetzt sie halten
sich die anderen noch zurück weil Sie
wahrscheinlich darauf hoffen dann doch
noch mal ein schwereren Schlag zu führen
der zu einem Durchbruch führt auch ein
durchgehäuser natürlich nicht einfach
selbst wenn er gelingt muss man dann
lange Flanken absichern und da darf man
nicht vergessen dass die Entfernung bis
zum Wunschziel also etwas bis zum Meer
bis zur Küste doch 80 bis 100 km
entfernt liegt und dann kann man auch
messen was erforderlich ist wie viel
minenräumgerät nötig ist wie viel
Flankenschutz dann nötig wird auch durch
verschiedenste Gruppen und Panzerabwehr
natürlich immer wieder die Artillerie
die Luftabwehr das ist ganz wichtig weil
sie auch aus der Luft angegriffen werden
und mein Eindruck insgesamt ohne jetzt
nicht im Detail hier zu verzetteln ist
es wird ein hin und her an der Front
sicherlich noch geben es wird vielleicht
sogar operative Einbrüche geben aber
eine strategische Änderung dieses
Krieges sehe ich nicht und vermutlich
und das nimmt vielleicht die Fragen am
Ende schon ein bisschen vorweg wird
irgendwann mal die Ukraine dann vor der
Wahl stehen entweder noch mehr Verluste
in Kauf nehmen zu müssen ohne wirklich
einen strategischen tiefgreifenden
Erfolg zu erreichen oder eben sich auf
eine Verhandlungslösung hinzubewegen von
der wir im Moment auch noch nicht
absehen können wo diese etwa liegen soll
aber man merkt schon dass natürlich der
Unmut auf der ukrainischen Seite etwas
zunimmt
vermutlich stehen die Ukraine auch unter
politischen Druck wir haben nächste
Woche den NATO-Gipfel und man möchte
natürlich gerne Erfolge vorweisen nach
all den vielen Lieferungen aus den
Westen aber das wird schwer werden
lassen Sie uns über Verluste und Unmut
sprechen aber vorher gemeinsam auf eine
Karte schauen dass wir alle wissen
worüber wir reden über die aktuelle
Front lassen Sie uns gemeinsam auf die
Karte schauen also an die Front im Osten
und im Süden da gibt es Bewegung an
verschiedenen Stellen wir haben jetzt
auch eine Mazda zuvorbereitet die wir
zeigen können ganz genau russische
Truppen sind also offenbar auf dem
Vormarsch bei Liman und aber auch nah
abifa so sagt man das richtig so wie
marienka und dann aber auf der anderen
Seite gibt es natürlich auch bei der
ukrainischen Armee da gibt es wohl
teilweise ein vorwärts kommen so bei
Bach Mut heißt es da wird von Teil
erfolgen gesprochen das sagt zumindest
die stellvertretende ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerin und an der
Südfront gibt es auch intensive Kämpfe
zum Beispiel bei Ulrike aber da eben
bislang keine Berichte über größere
Erfolge
das klingt ja jetzt aber danach
zumindest dass es ein hin und her gibt
immer mal auch wieder kleine Teilerfolge
aber wenn wir mal über jetzt eben die
Verluste auch noch mal sprechen und ob
das Unmut hervorruft das hat uns ja
gerade schon angesprochen wenn das also
nicht so voran geht Herr Richter wie man
sich das vorstellen könnte das etwas an
dieser Moral der ukrainischen Soldaten
ändern ja bislang für den Erfolg so
wichtig war
ja ich meine das lässt sich ja nicht
ganz verändern dass man sich irgendwann
mal fragt wofür machen wir das also wie
viel Verluste müssen wir noch in Kauf
nehmen damit ein politisches Ziel
erreichbar ist und das politische Ziel
Nummer eins ist natürlich erstmal Stand
zu halten das hat man ja gemacht also
die wenn man sich die operativen
Frontlinien anschaut die es seit etwa
einem Jahr gibt dann haben sie sich ja
eigentlich nicht wesentlich verändert es
gab einzelne Rückzüge aber die hatten
bestimmt begründe also z.B die russische
Rückzug auch Schalke im September
letzten Jahres der Rückzug dann später
im Jahr aus Carson weil man wusste dass
man westlich des Nepper nicht mehr in
der Lage ist im Winter die Stellung zu
halten das war also eher geplant und der
Abzug aus Kiel im April das war ja
eigentlich eine politische Entscheidung
in erster Linie nachdem man ein
Zwischenergebnis bei Verhandlungen
erzählt hatte
danach sieht es aber nicht jetzt aus
dann in der Zwischenzeit sind viele
Dinge passiert die Russen haben
mobilisiert sie haben Land annektiert
was natürlich erstmal nicht hindenkbar
ist aus ukrainischer Sicht damit sind
die verhandlungsschancen natürlich fast
auf Null gesunken zunächst einmal aber
man muss dann auch die Ressourcen
beiderseiten sehen die Ressourcen die
Russen haben wie gesagt durch die
Mobilisierung jetzt Landstreitkräfte die
über 500.000 hinausgehen sie haben Zeit
gehabt sie zu trainieren und zu
integrieren und diese Streitkräfte sind
mit etwa 300.000 jetzt in der Ukraine im
Einsatz also weitaus stärker als zu
Beginn des Krieges und dahinter stehen
eben nochmal 200.000 interessante und
meine Auffassung ist dass die Russen
jetzt darauf warten bis der ukrainische
Angriff sich fest frisst und dann selbst
noch mal in die Gegend Offensive zu
gehen also die Gefahr besteht schon dass
man in einen langen jetzt kommt wieder
das böse Wort abnutzungskrieg hineingeht
bei dem sich strategisch nicht viel
ändert aber am Ende dann die
Verlustzahlen immer weiter in die Höhe
gehen und man sich die Frage stellt ja
wo und wann soll das eigentlich enden
und unter welchen Bedingungen ihr habt
schon viele Fragen im Stream gestellt
wir besprechen die auch gleich mit Herrn
Richter wir sprechen gleich weiter
wollen aber jetzt eben vor allem auch
mal auf die Opfer schauen die die Kämpfe
fordern unsere Reporter der in der
Ukraine ist zur Zeit daran war bei einer
Beerdigung eines ukrainischen Soldaten
hat einen Beitrag dazu vorbereitet
danach können wir mit ihm sprechen und
schauen jetzt erst zusammen den Film an
auf dem Mai garden in Kiew hat der 2014
für Freiheit demonstriert jetzt bekommt
er hier seine letzte militärische Ehre
Ivan schulgar ist einer von Tausenden
gefallenen ukrainischen Soldaten in
diesem Krieg und seit der begonnenen
Großoffensive werden es mehr die
Gesamtzahl ihrer toten Soldaten hält die
Ukraine geheim jede einzelne Beerdigung
hingegen ist öffentlich sofern es die
Angehörigen wünschen und es war Ivans
Wunsch möglichst alle die in Kanten auf
seiner Beerdigung zu wissen
über 20 Jahre waren wir eng befreundet
jeden Sommer sind wir zusammen in Ferien
gefahren ehrlich gesagt ich kann es
immer noch nicht glauben dass er nicht
mehr da ist er war die treibende Kraft
der gründete unsere Band
Ivan liebte Musik die laut ist Heavy
Metal er spielte den Bass vor dem Krieg
ging er mit seiner Hobby Band auf
Tournee er studierte in Kiew arbeitete
später als Tontechniker Ivan hinterlässt
einen inzwischen achtjährigen Sohn und
seine Frau Asia
ihr sagte Ivan er Kämpfe heute damit ihr
Sohn später nicht mehr in den Krieg
ziehen muss ein Leben in Freiheit und
Frieden wolle er ihm hinterlassen
er war so stur er hat mich oft verrückt
gemacht aber dann verstand ich dass dies
auch Verlässlichkeit bedeutet ich wusste
wenn ich mich mit allem was ich habe ihm
in den Weg Stelle er würde trotzdem zur
Armee gehen und auch zu den
gefährlichsten Einsätzen er sagte mir er
würde sich nur um Technik kümmern aber
ich wusste dass er ein vorderster Front
kämpfte
sein Sohn wird ohne Vater aufwachsen er
teilt dieses Schicksal mit vielen
Kindern in der Ukraine der Soldaten
Friedhof in Kiews Gräber verdichten sich
zu einem Faden mehr das steht nicht nur
für Patriotismus sondern auch für sehr
viel Leid
daran ist uns jetzt live zugeschaltet
aus nibro Sarah steigt denn die Sorge in
der Bevölkerung das eben bei dieser
Offensive nun zu viele der eigenen Leute
getötet werden
also die Sorge der Familien die Soldaten
im Krieg haben die stockte steigt auf
jeden Fall gerade auf so einer
Beerdigung ist ein eine große
Unverständnis zu spüren über den Mangel
an Flugabwehr über die fehlenden Räumen
Panzer und auch darüber dass keine Chats
in dem Maße geliefert sind dass die
Ukraine ihre Truppen am Boden
verteidigen könnte bei dieser
Großoffensive die Menschen wissen sehr
wohl dass der Angreifer das haben sie ja
im letzten Jahr aus der anderen
Perspektive gesehen mehr Verluste an
Soldaten Leben hat als der Verteidiger
und sie wissen dass es um ihre
Angehörigen und Menschen geht also die
Sorge ist groß sie ist riesig und ähm es
ist mischt sich auch so eine Portion
fast Wut ein dass
jedenfalls wenn man bei einer
beerdigungsgesellschaft ist das einfach
nicht schneller geliefert wurde das
alles so schleppend gegen diese
Diskussion kannten sie ja auch noch aus
dem letzten Jahr wo sie auch im Waffen
gebeten haben macht das auch etwas mit
dem Glauben an den Sieg den ja immer
ganz viele geteilt haben und sich da
ganz sicher waren dass das funktioniert
vielleicht sogar mit dieser Offensive
jetzt funktioniert
ja das eine ist ja der Glaube an den
Sieg der ist immer noch relativ
unerschütterlich und er war es ja auch
ganz am Anfang im letzten Jahr auch im
März wo die ukrainische Armee unsortiert
war überrumpelt wurde die Truppen vor
Kiew standen die Leute haben dran
geglaubt sie sind zu Armee gegangen
jetzt wissen sie aber um diese wie auch
Herr richtervollen erklärt hat um diese
strategische Lage und auch um die Waffen
die fehlen also von daher ist eine ist
der Glaube und das andere ist eine
Portion Realismus dass jetzt jeder
Quadratmeter der erobert werden soll
sehr viele ukrainische Menschen Leben
rettet und es ist auch ganz interessant
zu sehen wenn man die Wahrnehmung in der
Presse sich anschaut die der
internationalen Presse gerade in der
europäischen wird oft über Leoparden
Verluste gesprochen während wir hier
eher eine konzentrieren drauf
konzentrisch die Presse und auch die
Menschen mehr drauf konzentrieren dass
die Besatzung der Leoparden oft überlebt
hat und das ja auch der Sinn dieser Liv
Waffenlieferungen ist also hier
sieht man diesen Blick auf zum Beispiel
gelieferte Waffen die verloren gegangen
sind im Einsatz ganz anders als
in Westeuropa
Präsident selensky hat jetzt noch mal
ganz klar erneuert was er schon jetzt
seit mehreren Monaten ganz klar sagt die
Rückeroberung der Krim die sei die
Voraussetzung für ein Ende des Krieges
der Weg zur Krim ist noch ein weiter das
hatte eben auch Herr Richter schon
angesprochen die Hoffnung der
Bevölkerung ist die denn aber noch da
das ist also wirklich dazu kommen könnte
eine Befreiung der Krim dass die Truppen
also so weit vorstoßen wenn es jetzt
gerade so langsam so zäh geht
also auch da ist wiederum ein
Unterschied zwischen Hoffnung die die
Menschen haben ich war in einem Zentrum
für Flüchtlinge aus mariopol und dort
wünschen sich diese Menschen natürlich
nichts mehr als die Befreiung ihrer
Heimat und Heimatstadt sie zurückkehren
können und es wäre natürlich für Sie ein
harter Schlag wenn am Verhandlungstisch
entschieden würde dass mariopol nicht
mehr erobert wird dass dafür aber eine
stabile oder eine Grenzen Beziehung
stattfindet und eine Trennung des Landes
und so geht es eigentlich jedem der
Verwandte in dem russisch besetzten
Gebiet hat oder selbst daher kommt dass
er zumindest hofft dass seine Heimat
zurückerobe erobert werden kann von
daher die Hoffnung ist da um die
Schwierigkeit des Unterfangens wissen
sie auch und sie sind auch bereit dafür
vieles hinzunehmen z.B wir sprachen über
diese Opferzahlen die in der Ukraine in
ihrer Gesamtheit nicht erwähnt wird um
dem Feind keine keinen Überblick zu
geben über die Stärke der tatsächlich en
kämpfenden Soldaten das nehmen sie hin
obwohl es eigentlich natürlich ein
wichtiger Indikator wäre für die
Entscheidung und für den
gesellschaftlichen Diskurs wie lange
will man die Offensive aufrecht erhalten
um Gebiete zurück zu erobern und wie
viele Soldaten leben werden dafür fallen
Eindrücke von daraus hat für uns in der
Ukraine vielen Dank daran
und wir kommen zu euren Fragen ich habe
ein wenig sammeln können denn bei uns
ist jetzt wieder oberste Wolfgang
Richter der mit uns gemeinsam hier die
Lage einschätzt und er ist wieder bei
uns und die erste Frage jetzt auch in
Bezug ganz aktuell eben auf die Krim was
wir auch gerade von Dara Hassani gehört
haben die Frage kommt von
ixmac bei Youtube er oder sie möchte
wissen wie realistisch ist es dass die
Ukraine innerhalb dieses Jahres die
Landbrücke zur Krim die Halbinsel selbst
oder gar den Zustand vor Februar 22
erreichen könnte
also aus meiner Sicht ist das in diesem
Jahr ein sehr ambitioniertes Ziel und
ich kann mir eigentlich im Moment wenig
vorstellen dass das erreichbar ist wir
haben ja vorhin schon mal analysiert
welche Ressourcen beide Seiten haben wir
haben über die Verluste gesprochen
amerikanisch und britische Geheimdienste
haben sie Ende letzten Jahres bereits
auf jeweils 120.000
beziffert das schließt natürlich
verwundete ein und muss immer davon
ausgehen dass 20 bis 25% dann gefallen
sind aber das ist so eine Größenordnung
und hierzu kommen noch 30 bis 40.000
zivile Verluste die
unendlich im Moment etwas geringer aber
ich glaube das dürfte dann realistischer
sein wenn man auf diese Zahl kommt und
insofern
wird wahrscheinlich Kriegsverlauf dazu
führen dass es noch weitaus höhere
Verluste gibt ohne dass man die
operationsziele erreicht und das erste
war ja genannt worden also die Frage ob
man den Korridor durchschneiden sehen
kann das müsste dann schon eine sehr
wuchtige Bewegung sein noch haben die
Ukrainer Reserven die sie zurückhalten
mit der sie wohl wenn Sie die
Schwachstelle gefunden haben dann auch
durchstoßen wollen aber auch das sollte
man nicht überbewerten denn auf der
russischen Seite stehen eben auch
Reserven übrigens sehr großer Zahl
mittlerweile die ja wohl auch ihrerseits
einem Gegenangriff planen sollte sich
die ukrainische gegen Offensive
festfressen also das ist ein
ambitioniertes Unternehmen natürlich
wenn es gelänge das asozial mehr zu
erreichen dann wäre die Landverbindung
zur Kremmen durchtrennt das heißt sie
wäre logistisch nur noch über die Brücke
von Kersch oder auch über den Seeweg er
sicherzustellen und oder über den
Luftweg und was würde natürlich schon
ein erheblichen ein eine erbliche
Einbuße bedeuten und die ganze Lage auf
der Krämpfe die Russen natürlich auch
sehr gefährlich macht sie werden also
alles versuchen den zu halten
die weiteren Ziele die sie jetzt genannt
haben also an die Krim zurückzuobern die
wurden schon vor mehreren Wochen selbst
von Amerikanern die es sicherlich auch
vernünftig bewertet haben in Frage
gestellt unter anderem vom Außenminister
blinken aber auch vom Generalstab statt
Familie das heißt da war er die Frage
gestellt worden ob man so nah an die
Creme heran kommt dass man dann
möglicherweise über weitreichende Waffen
oder durch den Einsatz weitreichender
Waffen entsprechende depotsflugplätze
etc oder auch helfen angreifen kann um
dann diese Situation um haltbar zu
machen das wäre jetzt zumindest operativ
gesehen ein sicherlich
ein Ziel dass man erreichen könnte denn
es gab ja schon solche Angriffe auf
bestimmte Plätze in der Krems das Ziel
die territuale Integrität
herzustellen im gesamten das ist ein
Ziel dass er der Präsident ausgegeben
hat das glaube ich ist offen gesagt
nicht erreichbar außer es würde das
Eintreten was ja in der Geschichte immer
wieder vorkam also eine Entwicklung die
unabs selber oder unvorhersagbar ist
weil sich plötzlich etwas ganz anderes
ereignet hat nicht ein Durchbruch an der
Front sondern zum Beispiel eine
innenpolitische Destabilisierung das
berühmte Beispiel ist die
Oktoberrevolution von 1917 im Ersten
Weltkrieg in Russland und nicht umsonst
hat vor dem Jahr auf diese Revolution
Bezug genommen nach diesem kurzaufstand
von triggershings das ist aber jetzt
kein Thema mehr wahrscheinlich dort
so dass ich davon ausgehe dass so eine
Entwicklung schwarze Schwäne wenn man ja
auch sagt er unwahrscheinlich ist bleibt
dann noch die Frage könnte man diese
Situation vom 24 Februar letzten Jahres
wieder erreichen das hängt eng mit der
Frage der territualen Integrität
allerdings zusammen da bin ich auch
etwas skeptisch und ein Punkt den
sollten wir nicht übersehen bei all
diesen Spekulationen über das was
erreichbar ist natürlich ist die
ukrainische Kampfmoral ungeheuer hoch
und das ist ja bewunderungswürdig wie
hoch sie ist und die ukrainische
Identität ist gewachsen und wenn es ein
Geburtshelfer gab der die Zweifel an der
Existenz und der Identität der
ukrainischen Nation nun beseitigt hat
dann war es Putin selbst der hat dazu
beigetragen aber es gibt natürlich
Bevölkerungsteile wenn auch eine
Minderheiten die in diesen in dieser
Nationalität oder nationale Identität
nicht eingeschlossen sind und das sind
die Kämpfer auf der anderen Seite die ja
verfassungsgemäß eigentlich auch
Ukrainer sind also das erste und zweite
Chor aus Lukas kommt kommt jetzt mit den
Familien wir sprechen hier über etwa
35.000 Soldaten wir sprechen über
Angehörige der früheren ukrainischen
Schwarzmeerflotte die schon 2014
übergelaufen sind und jetzt auf der
anderen Seite denen und wir sprechen
natürlich auch über die Affinitäten die
es in diesem östlichen und südlichen
Randbereichen gibt man kann sie ja nicht
alle aus Operateure behandeln das wusste
man auch schon bei den Minsk Abkommen
das heißt man muss auch dafür eine
Lösung finden um nicht anschließend
selbst wenn das alles gelänge dieser
Ambitionen dann einen anderen Guerilla
Krieg zu bekommen der dann umgekehrt
geführt wird nämlich aus sich dieser
Minderheit also das ist dann eben auch
noch zu lösen aber wenn man alles
zusammenzieht unterm Strich da wird es
so sein dass die Ukraine alles tun
werden und sollten ihre
Verhandlungsposition zu verbessern dass
der Krieg durch die Schlacht entschieden
wird als ich jetzt im Moment aus
heutiger Sicht für ihre wahrscheinlich
angesprochen die Ukraine alles dafür tun
wird ihre Verhandlungsposition zu
verbessern es gab eine Meldungen in den
letzten Tagen die hat auch horchen
lassen und zwar haben US-Medien
berichtet über den Besuch von CIA
Direktor burns in der Ukraine das war
aber wohl dann schon einige Tage vorher
das ist aber jetzt eben erst
rausgekommen berichtet worden und dem
nach also laut dieser US-Medien Berichte
glaubt KF also bis zum Herbst
beträchtliche Gebiete zurückerobern zu
können und was passiert dann dann soll
Artillerie und Raketensysteme in der
Nähe der von Russland kontrollierten
Krim verlegt werden und wenn dann es
soweit gekommen wäre so heißt es in dem
berichten dann würde man mit versuchen
mit Moskau dann doch Verhandlungen
aufzunehmen und das klang er jetzt
wirklich immer ausgeschlossen ist das
denn ihrer Meinung nach ein
realistisches Szenario also sind da
wirklich Verhandlung denkbar wenn der
Präsident also gestern noch sagt ohne
die Krim ist kein Ende des Krieges zu
machen
naja es gab ja mal eine Situation wo auf
der Präsident letztlich ja schon
zugestimmt hat dass es auch andere
Lösungen gibt ich erinnere an den
Vorschlag diese Zwischenlösung die er
von den Verhandlungsdelegationen nach 29
März letzten Jahres in Istanbul
vorgestellt worden waren da war die
Lösung dass man erstens auf die auf den
NATO-Beitritt verzichtet zweitens die
den Status den politischen Status der
Krim um 15 Jahre hinausschiebt und dann
eine Lösung zu finden aber das heißt ja
auch de factor Anerkennung der
russischen Kontrolle für 15 Jahre nicht
der Jura also nicht rechtlich gesehen
aber immerhin das ist schon eine andere
Situation und dann sollten die
Präsidenten direkt über ein Sonderstatus
der ist dann was verhandelt das hört
sich so nach links 3 also aber
Sonderrechte und spezialrechte
eingeräumt worden wären und der vierte
Punkt ohne jetzt ohne militäre Maßnahmen
und alles andere noch zu erwähnen wäre
die Frage der Sicherheitsgarantien für
die Ukraine gewesen eine Frage die
natürlich heute wieder ganz Viren Lösung
wie auch nächste Woche sicherlich in
Vilnius zur Sprache kommen wird aber
diese Verhandlungsposition sind ja schon
einmal zumindest vorläufig von den
autorisierten Delegationen akzeptiert
worden und sie sind allerdings jetzt
überholt worden sie sind überholt worden
zum Beispiel im September letzten Jahres
durch die an die weiteren Annexionen die
Russland vorgenommen hat das hat
natürlich die Tür für Verhandlung
zunächst einmal geschlossen aber der
Druck unter dem man jetzt dann steht
wenn die Operation nicht zum Erfolg
kommen also die gegen Offensive und wenn
man vor der Wahl steht muss man wieder
verhandeln oder soll man noch weitere
zigtausende von Pfoten in Kauf nehmen
ich glaube dann wird irgendwann sich die
werkschale zugunsten der Verhandlungen
neigen hinzukommen ja auch die Risiken
die es gibt dann wenn man einen sicheren
einen langfristigen Krieg an einem
langfristigen Krieg orientiert dann muss
man auch sicher gehen dass langfristig
die politische aber auch
und logistischer Unterstützung des
Westens aufrechterhalten bleibt dazu
gibt es zwar jetzt natürlich die feste
Entschlossenheit der westlichen
Staatschefs aber wir wissen ja nicht was
die Risiken in Zukunft sein werden und
es geht schon mal los mit dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen im nächsten Jahr
in den USA und ich erinnere daran wenn
ein Präsident wie Donald Trump noch
einmal an die Regierung kommt oder ein
ähnlich gearteter Präsidenten kann sich
diese Lage schon wieder verändern all
das zusammengenommen spricht nicht
unbedingt dafür dass ein langer Krieg
zugunsten der Ukraine ausgehen muss oder
für das ukrainische Volk Mann von
Vorteil wäre sondern ich glaube dass der
Druck zu verhandeln schon steigen wird
und das wird sich in den nächsten Wochen
herausstellen wenn man sieht welche
Ressourcen aufeinander treffen und wie
schwierig es sein wird irgendwelche
größeren Erfolge sprechen nicht von
kleineren Bewegungen an der Front die
wird immer geben aber ich meine wirklich
strategische Erfolge zu erzählen
es gibt Kommentare dazu und Fragen im
Stream Manfred peumer Pollmer richtig ja
kommentiert auf Facebook ich bin immer
noch der Meinung der einzige Weg um den
Krieg zu beenden sind ernsthafte
Verhandlungen möge die Voraussetzungen
noch so schwierig sein jeder Tote ist
einer zu viel und es gibt viele Fragen
jetzt gerade auch in Bezug auf die
aktuelle Offensive ich möchte die so ein
bisschen bündeln dann können Sie das in
einer Antwort vielleicht zusammenfassen
es gibt einmal die Frage von Poki Frosch
er fragt bei Youtube welches Ziel hatte
die Offensive dann fragt icke was
spricht denn dafür dass diese gegen
Offensive noch ein Erfolg werden könnte
und dann auch hier noch zusammengefasst
mit der Frage von Maximilian Benzinger
was würde eine gescheiterter Offensive
für die Ukraine bedeuten wäre dass der
Anfang vom Ende also was war das Ziel
dann was spricht dafür dass noch was
werden könnte und was bedeutet ein
Misserfolg
ja das erklärte Ziel das politische Ziel
zumindest ist die Wiederherstellung der
territoren Integrität das hat die
ukrainische Regierung immer wieder
betont ich glaube dass das Militär da
etwas nüchterner denkt und sagt das
operative Ziel müsste es eigentlich sein
den Korridor zu durchtrennen der die
kennen und den Don was verbindet
möglichst also ein Vorstoß bis zu der
Küste das auch schon Meeres und zum
anderen natürlich auch die russischen
starken Stellungen und Truppen im
Dornbach soweit zurückzubringen dass
auch die Russen unter Druck geraten das
wäre ein militärisch zumindest eher
erreichbares Ziel was spricht für ein
Erfolg der Gegend Offensive war die
Frage Nummer zwei
ich meine es bleibt glaube ich bei den
grundsätzlichen Einschätzung dass die
Kamera der Ukraine wirklich besonders
weit hoch ist das muss man eindeutig
sagen dass sie auch ihre taktischen
Operation gut koordinieren kann dass sie
sehr gut Aufklärung und Drohnen
aufeinander abstimmen was sie aber noch
nicht gezeigt haben das ist größere
angriffsbewegungen gut zu koordinieren
da sind sie noch in einem Hybriden
System das teilweise noch sowjetisch
denkt und teilweise NATO-Standards
übernommen hat sie sind noch nicht ganz
dort bei westlichen Vorstellungen
das ist nur an den Mitteln liegt glaube
ich nicht denn die Ukraine hatten wir
von Beginn an eine sehr sehr starke
Armee die Russen sind große riesigen
eingegangen gegen eine sehr starke auch
panzerstarke Armee vorzugehen es war die
zweitstärkste in Europa nach den Russen
und sie haben natürlich die Quittung
erhalten weil sie die Risiken völlig
unterschätzt haben mittlerweile haben
sie allerdings gelernt und die Russen
machen diese großen Fehler nicht mehr
wie sie am Anfang gemacht haben aber Sie
haben immer noch ein paar Dinge die Sie
einfach nicht hinkriegen zum Beispiel
die Initiative auf der unteren
Führungsebene sie fehlt völlig das haben
die Ukraine sehr gut drauf ähm auch
teilweise noch immer Mängel in der
kordelierung des gefechtsverbunden
generell sind jetzt besser geworden
und auf der operativen Ebene sind die
Ukrainer noch nicht dort wo sie sein
mussten um so eine Operation wirklich
erfolgreich zu führen und das hängt
nicht nur damit zusammen dass es
bestimmte Waffensysteme noch brauchte
diese eventuell zu wenig haben also die
Flugabwehr der Bodentruppen die im
Angriff sind sie haben da einiges sie
haben eigene System und sie haben die
Geparden etc die mitfahren mit der
Truppe aber da kann man natürlich noch
mehr tun das ist völlig klar das wird
man immer sagen in einem Gefecht wir
brauchen mehr aber es ist nicht so dass
generell diese diese Elemente fehlen
aber Sie müssen halt gut koordiniert
werden und das spricht alles dafür dass
sie vielleicht noch Teil Erfolge
erzielen aber nicht den ganz großen
strategischen Rückruf und dann die
letzte Frage was bedeutet eine
gescheiterte Offensive eine gescheiterte
Offensive muss natürlich nicht bedeuten
dass das Ende der Ukraine wäre es kann
genauso gut sein dass der Krieg sich da
mehr oder mindert das vielleicht die
großen noch ein paar Gelände Gewinne
machen dass sie aber auch die Russen
eher vor dem Dilemma jetzt weitere
oberung halten zu müssen
mehr Verluste noch mal einzuplanen ihre
eigene Stellung auch gegenüber der NATO
lässt sich zu schwächen das darf man
nicht ganz vergessen Sie werden aus
diesem Krieg herauskommen mit
geschwächten und überdehnten
Landstreitkräften und das ist auch keine
so ganz gute Nachricht weil damit
natürlich auch der Fokus eher auf
Nuklearwaffen liegt wenn es also um die
NATO geht also die aus russischer Sicht
die Defensive gegen die NATO auf einer
sehr sehr langen Frontlinie die jetzt
vom Nordkap runter reicht nach dem
finnischen Beitrag über die baltischen
Staaten bis runter nach zum Schwarzen
Meer das sind alles Überlegung und die
natürlich auch eine Rolle spielen ich
glaube eher dass die Russen dann wohl
ihre
bis jetzt bis jetzt besetzten Gebiete
halten vielleicht auch noch ausweiten
wollen ich würde auch nicht ausschließen
dass sie noch versuchen einen Stoß nach
Odessa durchzuführen wenn es ihm gelingt
noch mal über den Körper zu kommen das
alles ist denkbar aber die Ukraine
generell zu beherrschen halte ich für
unmöglich und ich glaube dass das auch
keiner mit Realität sind im russischen
generalsta plant weil man natürlich ganz
genau weiß dass der ukrainische
Widerstand dann eben auf viele
Jahrzehnte wahrscheinlich erhalten
bleibt und das ist nicht beherrschbar
Arthur Fritzlar kommentiert zur
Gegenoffensive hier bei uns bei Youtube
das geht über Monate und Monate was
erwartet man in Wochen ohne
Luftunterstützung läuft dann nichts und
Chris Watts schreibt wie sollen die
Ukraine gegen befestigte Stellung mit
Minenfeldern Vorgehen die Russen haben
auch Drohnen und beobachten jede
Bewegung mit Bradley und Mardern ist da
kein Durchkommen wenn wir darüber
sprechen über diese Lufthoheit der
Russen also hier Helikopter Kampfjets
Drohnen die das Fortkommen ja ganz klar
erschweren also der ukrainischen Armee
ist da nicht natürlich der Folge
richtige Schluss der Ukraine zu fordern
klar sie brauchen Kampfjets klar sie
brauchen da jetzt mehr Unterstützung ist
überhaupt ohne diese Unterstützung aus
dem Westen noch was zu erreichen
wenn sie auf die Angriff
angriffsfähigkeit hinaus wollen ich sage
noch einmal die verschiedenen Elemente
die man braucht für das Gefecht
verbundene Waffen und für operative
Angriffe sind im Prinzip vorhanden man
kann nie davon genug haben im Klaren
Gefecht muss man immer mehr haben aber
die Koordinierung glaube ich ist
wichtiger als alles andere es ist nicht
so dass die Ukrainer keine Luftwaffe
hätten sie haben eine sie ist sogar ganz
erfolgreich im Einsatz mittlerweile
britische weitreichende
Shadow man kann sie eben auch unter die
mit 29 also ein eher ein Modell das ja
auf serviertischer Bauarbeiten das sind
alles Dinge die macht was sind die F16
ist ein Kampfflugzeug das wird sehr
lange dauern es wird wahrscheinlich in
diesem Jahr kaum noch in den Einsatz
gehen können
aus dem User nämlich dazu warum bekommt
die Ukraine die F16 erst nach der
Offensive die Flieger wären doch jetzt
viel wichtiger
also zunächst mal sie haben selbst
Kampfhubschrauber und auch
Kampfflieger die F16 kann nicht sofort
in den Einsatz gehen selbst wenn sie
jetzt verfügbar wäre weil einfach die
Vorbereitungszeit zu lange dauert die
Piloten müssen völlig ungeschult werden
das dauert Monate das beginnt ja jetzt
erst die Logistik muss müsste
bereitgestellt werden einem
Kampfflugzeug ist nur so gut wie die
Logistik die ist dann auch da das ja nur
wenige Stunden gibt die sie fliegen
können also die Logistik ist ganz
wichtig die Wartung die Ersatzteile und
vor allen Dingen die Munition das
Kampfflugzeug ist ja immer nur die eine
Seite der Diskussion die andere Seite
ist wie sind sie ausgerüstet welche
Munition haben Sie welche
Aufklärungsmittel haben sie wie gut ist
die Luftraum Überwachung dort und das
Luftlage Bild alter das ist wichtig und
auch die die Führung sozusagen der
kampflieger vom Boden aus in Richtung
Feind oder über die Frage also der
entsprechenden Radarsysteme auch der
Aufklärung die über den Westen natürlich
teilweise läuft all das erst macht Sinn
also nicht über ein einzelnes System zu
reden das Gesamtsystem ist auch hier
wieder entscheidend es wird nicht mehr
rechtzeitig kommen in diesem Jahr da bin
ich glaube ich
einig mit vielen anderen Beobachtern die
sagen es
die Zeit wird dafür nicht reichen also
frühestens Ende des Herbst könnten die
ersten dann erscheinen dann muss man die
Ressourcen miteinander vergleichen über
wie viel Kampfflugzeuge reden wird die
russische Luftwaffe hatte zu Beginn 1300
Kampfflugzeuge insgesamt natürlich nicht
alle in der Ukraine ist
selbstverständlich sie haben viele
andere Bereiche diese weiter schützen
müssen trotzdem bleibt die Überlegenheit
deutlich wenn man sieht dass die Ukraine
zu Beginn 125 hatten also
10 % davon aber alle im Einsatz können
natürlich und diese Verluste müssen
ausgeglichen werden und wir reden im
Moment vielleicht über 30 40
das ist nicht die strategische Größe die
man bräuchte und jetzt große
strategische Umbrüche zu erreichen das
soviel zur ich glaube was wichtiger
Moment ist ist den eigenen Luftraum
durch Abwehr also durch Raketen und
Flugabwehr in den Griff zu bekommen da
kann man noch mehr tun da hat aber auch
das selenski deutlich gemacht dass zum
Beispiel Systeme wie die Iris steht ganz
hervorragend wird aber auch Patchwork
die ja immerhin schon geschafft haben
selbst diese angeblichen Wunderwaffen
also die kindscheibe Raketen dann zu
bekämpfen erfolgreich zu bekämpfen also
auch das mit ein bisschen Abstand als
würde eine weitere Frage gestellt das
hat was mit dem Drohnen sofort die
Drohnen da muss man unterscheiden
zwischen den Drohnen die man an der
Front einsetzt zur Aufklärung und so
unmittelbaren Koordination mit der
Artillerie Bekämpfung das machen wir
Ukraine ganz hervorragend davon haben
sie auch sehr viel und da haben sie sehr
viel auch vom Besten bekommen das ist
glaube ich einer der stärken
mindest um strategische bauen geht oder
sagen wir mal weitreichende Drohnen die
dann eher operative zähle im Hinterland
angreifen oder Gaststätte dann haben sie
natürlich nicht diese vergleichbaren
Waffen aber was wäre denn dann das Ziel
dann wäre das Ziel also auf russische
Stellung in Russland oder russische
Städte eben auch an zu fliegen und das
würde ja zwar eine Eskalation bedeuten
es hat ja teilweise Angriffe gegeben
aber es würde an der Front nicht viel
verändert also man muss dann schon den
Blick tatsächlich für die Front haben
und insofern ich schick mal die eine
Frage zu den Minenfelder noch mit rein
die Minenfelder sind ein typisches
Beispiel dafür dass man nicht den Krieg
dadurch betrachten darf durch die Linse
eines Waffensystems das war von Anfang
an ein bisschen schief auch in der
öffentlichen Darsteller es sind nicht
die einzelnen Waffensysteme die
entscheiden sind selbst wenn das ganz
wichtig ist dass man überlegen was hat
daran hat
ja darauf hingewiesen das ist in der Tat
beim Leoparden nicht so viel
personalverluste gibt selbst wenn er
getroffen worden ist kommt das Personal
leichter raus weil die Munition zum
Beispiel getrennt gelagert wird und
nicht neben dem Personal das sind alles
Dinge die eine Rolle spielen aber sie
spielen keine entscheidende Rolle für
die Frage wie man Operation am Ende
führt und gewinnt der dazu muss man
alles Systeme haben die nötig sind um
eben durch Minenfelder dann möglichst
rasch hindurchzukommen also wie ein
Panzer aber auch anderes
minenrollengerät dass man beispielsweise
fern verstehst um Schneisen zu schlagen
und natürlich auch ähm selbst die
Fähigkeit gleichzeitig zu haben Männer
schnell zu verlegen über Minenwerfer
wenn es darum geht die eigenen Flanken
Gegenangriffe zu schützen aber das sind
jetzt nur Beispiele wir müssen also
alles Systeme immer in Kombination sehen
von der Artillerie über die infanterien
Schützen fahren sondern über die
Kampfpanzer die Pioniere die ja beides
machen die Bewegung vorbereiten die
überflüsse setzen können die die
Minenfelder legen aber sie haben also
das sind Dinge die zusammengehören und
selbstverständlich die Flugabwehr um
solche Operation überhaupt erst möglich
zu machen und was natürlich neben dem
Material neben den Waffensystem eine
große Rolle spielt wie viele Menschen
habe ich mit denen ich da in den Kampf
ziehen die die bedienen können deswegen
ganz zum Schluss noch die Frage an Sie
aus dem Stream wie viel man könnte die
Ukraine noch realistisch mobilisieren
das spielt ja eine Rolle wenn jetzt
immer mehr Soldaten an der Front
verwendet werden
also ich glaube es gibt durchaus noch
reservepersonal in der Ukraine das auch
noch mobilisiert werden kann es gibt
Angaben vom Institut für strategische
Studien vom internationalen Institut für
strategische Studien in London die die
etwa bei 400.000 Mann beziffern die
Frage ist allerdings in der Tat wie
viele werden jetzt unabhängig noch
unabhängig gestellt muss man dafür also
andere Regeln jetzt haben damit man noch
mehr Personal gewinnt und ich fand das
schon bemerkenswert das mittlerweile
rekrutierungs-teams durch odesser gehen
und Leute auf der Straße ansprechen ob
sie sich nicht mal melden wollen also
das sind dann Männer im mittleren Alter
sie haben die 40 oder bisschen drunter
bisschen drüber also die ganz große
Begeisterung scheint nicht mehr da zu
sein aber doch noch
sicherlich ein sehr sehr hohes Maß ab
patrismus und auch
opferungswellen das muss man den
Ukrainern wirklich unter wann das in ein
Zustand des Fatalismus übergeht wenn die
Erfolge ausbleiben das kann man jetzt im
Moment nur spekulieren aber ich
befürchte dass irgendwann der Punkt
kommt wo man sagt ja klar ich bleibe
loyal zu meinem Land aber ich habe keine
große Hoffnungen mehr und ich hoffe dass
dieser Punkt nicht insofern
durchschlagen ist dass es dann zur
größeren Einbußen kommt sondern dass die
Politik das rechtzeitig erkennt und sagt
jetzt wird es aber Zeit eine andere
Lösung vielleicht über Verhandlung dann
auch
zu
bewerkstelligen Einschätzung von Oberst
Adi Wolfgang Richter vielen lieben Dank
dafür dass sie so viel Zeit für uns
heute hatten danke
gerne alles Gute danke und ich habe auch
gesehen dass ihr das zu schätzen wusstet
dass wir also hier so viele Fragen von
was da die Richter beantwortet bekommen
haben und möchte hier noch einen letzten
Kommentar vielleicht von euch vorlesen
und zwar Tommy Tom der sieht das Ganze
hier ein bisschen optimistisch und sagt
ich glaube es ist noch alles offen und
die Ukraine hat den Großteil ihrer für
die eroberungstruppen ihre Rückeroberung
Truppen den Großteil davon noch nicht
eingesetzt also hier ein wenig Hoffnung
im Stream dass das für die Ukraine
zumindest noch gut ausgehen könnte und
wir sagen für heute vielen Dank viele
Fragen waren es und ihr wisst ihr seid
auch jederzeit bei uns hier wieder mit
einem Update zur Ukraine auch in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen gut versorgt
deswegen seid gerne wieder dabei bis
dahin tschüss